foreign
part of your work is you run a robotics
lab if a student were to join your lab
what's it like to show up at work in the
morning in the lab it's not all that
different from running machine learning
experiments where you run code you try
to train a model and then evaluate that
model there's also interfacing with the
real robot oftentimes a lot of projects
might start with a simulation and that
might involve actually kind of Designing
aspects of the simulation to test the
hypotheses you want to test and on the
real robot there is setting up the
control stack such that you can actually
command the robot setting up the cameras
collecting data and you may want to
actually look at the images that the
robot is seeing maybe visualize some of
the features that your model has learned
it's a pretty fun process at least for
me I think it's very rewarding to
actually see the robot do something
rather than just see some numbers or
some accuracy of your model but it's
also requires persistence because robots
can break down it used to Solutions so
every time a helicopter crash we have to
just go build a new one yeah
unfortunately arms Do Not Crash too much
maybe I should have chosen working on
that instead foreign